Transcriber: Yiğit Yıldırım
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Kafam bozuk
Gönlüm soluk
Dilim donuk
Bu dümende.
Saçım ağarır
Yaşım bağırır
Yaşam daralır
Bu dümende.
Aşkı için ölecek,
Nerde kaldı öyle yürek!
Delikanlı yoruldu
Bir o yana bir bu yana, sararıp soldu.
Aşkı için ölecek,
Nerde kaldı öyle yürek!
Delikanlı yoruldu.
Bir o yana bir bu yana, sararıp soldu.
Hakkım kalır
Helal bağırır
Nazım çalınır
Bu dümende.
Saçım ağarır
Yaşım bağırır
Yaşam daralır
Bu dümende.
Aşkı için ölecek,
Nerde kaldı öyle yürek!
Delikanlı yoruldu.
Bir o yana bir bu yana, sararıp soldu.
Aklı selim bahaneler
Daha ne durur haneler?
Delikanlı yoruldu
Bir o yana bir bu yana; sararıp soldu.
(Alkış)
Bak işte yaklaşıyor fırtına
Bak yine yükseliyor dalgalar
Yıllardan sonra, yollardan sonra
Şarkılar söylüyor çocuklar
Yeniden yanyana onlar
Ne geçmiş tükendi ne yarınlar
Hayat yeniler bizleri
Geçse de yolumuz bozkırlardan
Denizlere çıkar sokaklar
Bak işte yaklaşıyor fırtına
Bak yine yükseliyor dalgalar
Yıllardan sonra, yollardan sonra
Şarkılar söylüyor çocuklar
Yeniden yan yana onlar
Ne geçmiş tükendi ne yarınlar
Hayat yeniler bizleri
Geçse de yolumuz bozkırlardan
Denizlere çıkar sokaklar
Ne geçmiş tükendi ne yarınlar
Hayat yeniler bizleri
Geçse de yolumuz bozkırlardan
Denizlere çıkar sokaklar
Yıllardan sonra, yollardan sonra
Şarkılar söylüyor çocuklar
Yeniden yanyana onlar
(Alkış)